2020 is obviously front and center and
two of the Democratic presidential
candidates appear to poll appear by
polling to have a chance at beating
president Trump that would be senator
Bernie Sanders and former Vice President
Joe Biden so while both candidates have
a slight edge over the
commander-in-chief most surveys show
Biden as the front-runner
senator Sanders comes in as the second
choice here via Skype to discuss this
trend is David Pakman he's a political
commentator and host of the David Pakman
show David thank you so much for joining
us great to be with you David one of the
things we're taking a look at on the
show a lot is about how Bernie Sanders
comes in is one of the I think he's the
number two choice for several of the
candidates within the field basically
making it poised so if that there is a
bite and implosion or a dropout or
what-have-you he would likely be the
nominee what is what are you taking a
look at in terms of this polling what do
you think it reveals about the race yeah
a couple different things one is that if
you look historically so August of 2015
which is sort of like where we are right
now in 2020 if you look at oddest of
2011 August of 2007 typically whoever is
leading primary polling right now goes
on and ends up being the nominee but
there have been some pretty close calls
so for example with the Democrats back
in 2016 meaning in late 2015
Bernie Sanders actually came all the way
back to get within the margin of error
of tying Hillary Clinton and then
started dropping and as we know Hillary
Clinton ultimately became the nominee so
one thing to pay attention to is that
even though the the sort of most likely
scenario is that Biden the leader right
now in most polling ends up being the
nominee it doesn't necessarily have to
be that way historically it could be
could be warned as well as Bernie
Sanders and interestingly often when you
ask people who do you think will
ultimately be the nominee as opposed to
saying who do you support
polling is more accurate in that way and
one way to look at that is the
prediction markets where people are able
to actually kind of bet bet with their
money as to who they think will be the
nominee and Joe Biden is not actually
leading there it's actually Elizabeth
Warren recently who has taken the lead
there and
that's an interesting turn of events I
think we should pay attention to I think
that is fascinating I mean lay on the
pack for her because one of the
challenges she has to overcome is she
still has a mostly sort of white
educated liberal coalition and obviously
you can't win the primary without
expanding to have a large base among
people of color too so what do you see
is the path for her
yeah I've not seen that particular data
not that it doesn't exist I just haven't
seen it because I think at this point
it's it's less important than who is
being substantive and pushing policy in
depth and that's basically how she's
picked up about a point to a point and a
half a month going all the way back to
March which is she put out a
extraordinarily detailed proposal about
education she put out a detailed
proposal about lowering wealth and
income inequality she recently put one
out about the internet public option and
restoring net neutrality and she's been
actually gaining without any you know
debate killshot attempts without sort of
campaign ads or superficial stuff she's
just been going out and talking to
voters including in red states that
Donald Trump won in 2016
and talking about policy which is a very
different approach than the other
candidates have seen who have sort of
jumped and fallen much more erratically
it's been a slow and steady gain for
Elizabeth Warren on policy David one of
the things you're also known for is very
good media analysis I have noticed that
Elizabeth Warren has generally received
pretty favorable coverage in the
mainstream media but that Bernie Sanders
certainly has had his own you know his
own quibbles with them we have a latest
story from the New York Times about why
Bernie Sanders stood out at the Iowa
State Fair it claims that he didn't want
to make personal contact with voters
despite drawing some of the biggest
crowds there I mean just yesterday
Bernie went after the Washington Post
for coverings covering some of the labor
disputes within his campaign claiming
that they were doing so because they
were owned by Amazon's CEO Jeff Bezos
the world's richest man what do you make
of this media coverage and then the
Senators response and how he's handling
that yeah I mean I think that the thing
I would sort of zoom out a little bit
which is that when we look at the
interactions of candidates with voters
in
general both Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren do really well in front
of crowds where they are talking about
policies so if you look at Bernie
Sanders and his Fox News Town Hall that
he did where he had an entire room of
people selected for that Town Hall
raising their hands saying yeah I would
prefer the plan that you're proposing
instead of what we have now the Fox News
host didn't know what it hit him it
looked like they were in a twilight zone
is that what's going on they're like
this is we can't ever do this again he
actually gets to talk to people
Elizabeth Warren is going in to talk to
crowds as I said in red states so you
know I don't know exactly what happened
at this fair I've not been to many of
these fairs and don't really know what
the dynamics are like but big picture he
is a candidate that's connecting with
voters just like Elizabeth Warren is
yeah yeah I mean I think that's what
people well you know raising a skeptical
eyebrow at least Sanders supporters
about this piece to say the least
because here he goes the Iowa State Fair
by a lot of accounts he draws the
largest crowd he is way more grassroots
donors in the state than any other
candidate and this is the angle that
they choose to take seemed a little
strange but I also wanted to get your
thoughts on there's a conversation
happening right now around Joe Biden and
his gaffes or slips of the tongue or
whatever you want to call it seem to be
coming at a very frequent pace and are
raising questions in people's minds
about whether he in fact is the
candidate to be Donald Trump if he is
the most quote-unquote electable one do
you think that this sort of thing could
ultimately hurt him or do you think it's
kind of baked into the Joe Biden cake
well listen I mean the the recent
comment Joe Biden made about I think it
was poor kids or just as smart as white
kids and then he sort of fumbled and
said oh I mean wealthy kids and Latino
kids and Asian kids or whatever else to
say that that's evidence that Joe Biden
holds some kind of deep-seated racist
belief I think goes too far I guess
certainly it's evidence that it's sort
of a slower and more tired Joe Biden
than we've seen it's a Joe Biden who as
we know may not sort of like be
sensitive to the 2019 way of talking
about some of these things but as far as
electability the most recent poll on
that is a survey USA poll which has both
Biden and Bernie
52:42 over Trump in a hypothetical
national election now that's only 92% of
the vote obviously those are not going
to be the final numbers there's 8% there
that at some point is going to coalesce
behind either the Democratic nominee
Trump or some third party I don't think
that the Democratic nominee is going to
win the popular vote by eight but
looking back in 2016 where these numbers
are starting to resemble what they could
be which is that you could have a
Democratic nominee be a Biden or Bernie
or Warren or whoever else who does win
the popular vote by two or three points
as Hillary Clinton did but could win or
lose the electoral college and that's
why I've been saying this is ultimately
going to come down to turnout this is
going to come down to some smaller
sliver of the votes in a few key states
will it be 75,000 in three states as it
was in 2016 I don't know but we we are
likely going in the direction of a
Democratic nominee winning the popular
vote but maybe not winning the electoral
college
David I totally agree with you there
everybody note it up you know behind
closed doors most people in the Trump
campaign would admit the same thing so
the question I have for you is which of
the candidates right now or which
philosophy right now is battis poised to
win the popular and electoral college
well I think the mistake for Democrats
would be to believe that playing to the
middle is the way to capture centrist
votes or even disaffected center-right
Trump voters I mean that's what
Democrats have always tried by chance it
will sometimes work and it will often
not and I think it's abundantly clear
that on the issues Democrats do better
when they are strong about economic
inequality this includes health care
this includes education this includes
taxation I think it's also important not
to get confused and start paying too
much attention to non voting issues or
issues that are non voting issues for
the left but will often affect
right-wing voters so gun control is one
health care for undocumented immigrants
is another I think that by and large the
progressive wing of the Democratic Party
does have the right ideas but if we
allow particularly as we've seen in the
debate so far
the framing around a lot of these issues
to play directly into the Republican
framing I think it's just
self-destructive for Democrats and that
would also be a mistake yeah that's
definitely been the approach that the
moderators have been taking the
candidates a lot of cases have played
right into it great to see you David
thank you so much thanks David
always a pleasure thank you next on
rising airports are closed for a second
day in Hong Kong s pro-democracy
protests continue and the trade war
between China and the u.s. begins to
show an impact on the global economy
expert gordon chang unpacked these
developments with us next